on Prime crime
we don't know yet it's not looking good
a day at the movies becomes its own
lethal drama one thing led to another
and erupted into the biggest nightmare
she's ever had and unfortunately
continues to relive you second guessed
the very fact that you were even hit
I second guess every step of that
encounter
foreign
everybody I'm Jesse Weber and welcome to
Prime crime this is where we break down
the most high profile and memorable True
Crime cases a movie theater is typically
a place to sit back relax have some fun
and be entertained but as you're about
to see one theater became the scene of a
deadly confrontation
if I had it to do over again it would
never happen
[Music]
this is the voice of 71 year old Curtis
Reeves a former Florida police captain
how long you been retired
wow very well trained he was I would say
better trained in law enforcement and in
the use of Defense tactics he was the
one that developed the first SWAT team
ever in the history of the Tampa Police
Department Reeves is recounting to law
enforcement the events that transpired
on January 13 2014 when he and his wife
went to a Wesley Chapel Florida movie
theater to see Mark Wahlberg's film Lone
Survivor well we were watching the
movies hey guys
[Music]
okay
[Music]
I said I asked him to turn his cell
phone officers
okay so he kept doing it reads
describing his interaction with 43 year
old Chad Olson a Navy veteran and father
who was sitting in the row in front of
Reeves with his wife Nicole so that day
was just a day that Nicole and Chad were
taking a date day and they just decided
to go out for the day and shop and catch
a movie and hang out and one thing led
to another and her entire life was
turned upside down so what happens then
come back in the movies
[Music]
he said something about he was it was us
I always texting my daughter or
something like that and you stay the
hell out of my face they walk into the
movie theater they're sitting down
they're casually talking and Nicole just
assuming this is another great gate day
with her the love of her life and over a
cell phone during previews uh erupted
into the greatest nightmare she's ever
had and unfortunately continues to
relive
D like
it was I think he had a cell phone in
his hand the history in the face and
locks my glasses sideways on leaning
back he's virtually in my lap I'm I got
it I got contact with something with my
left hand it's dark in there I mean I
mean suddenly this happened so damn fast
and the ridiculous bullets hit the
upward because I came out of my pocket
with it coming around
in that instant Curtis Reeves shot and
killed Chad Olson the movie
the movie footage is
you cannot see Mr Olson there's really
no evidence as to his proximity exactly
uh to Mr Reeves his facial expressions
his body language it's just very
difficult to really glean exactly what's
happening
it don't make it even easier for me for
me to accept it but that's what I'm
saying Curtis Reeves is arrested and
would be charged with the murder of Chad
Olson the legal question now was this
self-defense under Florida law when the
incident took place because the law used
to be that the burden was on the
defendant to show that he was immune
that he was entitled to immunity for
shooting for just you know for shooting
someone or using self-defense then the
law changed to now the government the
state has the burden to show that the
the defendant was not justified
I would like to say no
I was surprised being a former season
law enforcement officer that he would
interview and this was very telling to
me because I believe that it shows how
strong Mr Reeves felt that he had done
nothing wrong
[Music]
in my opinion from minute one he knew
what he was able to get away with and
what he wasn't able to get away with
describing the incident so that he knew
that he could claim senior ground and
claim that this was an accident and not
an intentional killing or a murder
but unfortunately he had no idea that
there was a video
it's not looking good on January 13 2014
a Pasco County Florida movie theater
erupts into chaos when Curtis Reeves
shoots and kills Chad Olson after a
tense exchange over Olsen using his cell
phone in the theater Reeves claimed
Olson threw something at his face and
was about to attack him according to
Reeves in a desperate moment of survival
he fired his 380 semi-automatic handgun
but was this self-defense under the law
in order to answer that question we have
to analyze the various circumstances of
the shooting let's start with the scene
itself did you think that he had
something other than a cell phone
I I had no idea what what he had all I
knew was like I was coming after me it's
dark the theater's dark the show's on I
don't know him I don't know I see that
he's very explosive the movie theater
environment it almost couldn't have been
worse if you're seeing somebody come at
you in this dark environment with noise
I think it could have led Mr Reeves to
really perceive him as Mr Reeves said as
a monster then there's the fight leading
up to the shooting his wife and whoever
was really was trying to hold him back
right
what is he saying to you
get off get out of my face
what about just immediately prior to the
shop
whatever he was saying was was
threatening who's the aggressor I think
the uh the the defendant perhaps
initiated the you know the contact by
telling the gentleman the victim to turn
off the phone and of course the victim
persisting and using the phone and then
standing up and then confronting the old
man so you know it's hard to say who's
the aggressor my wife is saying
and when I got up to go tell the manager
she said why would you we should have
just moved the fucking show that she
said that afterwards right and she left
it right because that's exactly he left
the theater and left his wife next to
this uh supposed threat he also engaged
multiple times with Mr Olson if you felt
your life was in threat why would we
were being threatened why would you do
that to me this whole thing started was
because he was a law enforcement officer
and the founder of SWAT who used to tell
people jump and they would say how high
but because he was no longer a law
enforcement officer he didn't get the
respect that he that he felt that he
deserved one of the critical pieces of
contested evidence was that Reeves
claims Olson threw something at him do
you see anything in his hands I think he
has a cell phone I looked down and his
cell phone was laid at my feet so I
think that's what he did in the basement
Mr Olsen's phone that was located in
between his legs our theory in this case
was that Mr Olsen had thrown the phone
there was a clip showing Mr Olsen with a
hand movement over the back of the seat
uh depicting uh throwing something we
were able to through our experts be able
to analyze the actual pixels uh that
encompassed that light if there were six
pixels in a rectangular form
for a while there was kind of Dazed
and it had to be from the strike there
was some footage actually of Mr Reese's
face and
and uh somewhat of a pink uh marking on
the left side to counter that what
doesn't support that he was struck with
the cell phone a judge that ruled on uh
emotion earlier actually said they
thought that light was the reflection
off off of Mr Reeves's shoes then there
was the issue of if Olson was about to
attack I know I can't go anywhere he's
virtually on top of it but he's not
going to see him came over this in
between the crack between the two seats
that's when
as he come over the seat or is he still
on his rope his feet were on the seat at
least one of them was and he was pushing
back with his hand and he was coming
over the seat I'm pushing him off with
my left hand and I had a hole or
something I'm assuming it was probably
his chest
with your left hand
as he's coming over you actually make
contact with us I made contact with
something his arm is just a shoulder rod
the empirical evidence regarding whether
Mr Olsen was climbing over the sea is
very minimal that video that was taken
in that theater really doesn't show us
Mr Olsen so now we have to rely on what
other Witnesses saw what Mr Reeve saw so
all of that is
um subjective to a degree and some have
speculated that perhaps all Olson did
was flick popcorn in Reeves's face
[Music]
I'm not sure if I dropped it or if
people throw things at each other uh is
that enough to throw uh you know to
remove a gun and shoot somebody or is
popcorn deadly no not at all I I don't
think anybody believed the popcorn
defense no one agreed that the popcorn
was the the justification for shooting
the normal lay person out there uh they
really don't understand you know the
small fractions of a second that takes
place what Mr Reeves saw coming at him
was a fist a hand coming towards him
obviously he had no idea that you know
Mr Olsen was going to be grabbing the
popcorn any reasonable person would have
thought that a punch was going to be uh
thrown at that point in time and so Mr
Reeves reacts accordingly and in the
process of picking up the popcorn uh the
shot is fired so what made you shoot him
it scared the hell up in 2014 retired
police captain Curtis Reeves opens fire
in a Florida movie theater killing
husband and father Chad Olson Reeves
told police that he shot Olson after the
the two got into a heated exchange with
Reeves claiming Olson threw something at
him lunged towards him and was about to
attack
it was not a big deal but then when he
started forming he started yelling then
scared the crap out while Reeves would
be arrested and charged with murder in
2017 he tried to get the case thrown out
under Florida's stand your ground law
stand your ground is a very
controversial statute if a person is
where they're legally allowed to be they
have the right if they reasonably
believe that their life is being
threatened or serious bodily injury is
being threatened they can use deadly
force to stand their ground against that
perceived threat when you file a senior
ground motion you actually have the
motion heard before a trial because the
extender ground is granted you are
immune from being tried in the cases to
over at that point but they had a senior
ground trial that lasted several weeks
and after several weeks and lots of
testimony lots of experts and even a
visit to the movie theater itself the
judge determined that he was not allowed
to claim stand your ground it's
difficult for an elected judge to make a
decision a tough decision like this uh
on the bench and so now we were left
with using that same stand your ground
that same justifiable use of deadly
force now in front of a jury and with
that after eight years of delays
hearings motions and a pandemic Curtis
Reeves murder trial finally began in
2022 what the evidence will show you is
that Chad Olson was shot and killed over
tossing popcorn and the defendant States
some words to the effect of throw
popcorn at me or throw popcorn on my
face the evidence will show you that's
important for ill will and spite
and when you see the way he lunges
forward with the firearm and makes that
statement you get a clearer picture of
what was really going on he was walking
quickly
he was mumbling he seemed to be
to be upset or irate about something
like
throw popcorn at my face it was like
more like declaratory like like an out
of anger none of these officers
separated the witnesses they allowed
these witnesses to congregate amongst
each other to speak about what they had
seen dude unfortunately influence each
other over what they may have seen and
may have not seen But the jury would
also hear from a key witness too Chad's
Widow Nicole who is right next to him
during this whole event and was shot
herself he says I see you put your phone
away now that I went to get management
does your husband respond response he
does yes
and how does he respond
what's your problem at any time did you
hold restrain body hug or whatever they
can give someone the impression that you
were holding someone back that was in
her right
I mean I knew a shot could run out but I
didn't know where he was shot or what
really what our injuries were other than
my hands felt like it was going off of
my arm and I'm watching him collapse so
I sad and just shock I think panic I
thought she'd knock it out of the park
Nicole does not like to let people know
exactly how she's feeling all the time
as soon as she tries to hide her
emotions she was a little bit stoic
having to relive this yet again but I
thought she did incredible she just
handled herself amazing but when it came
to a defense Reeves's legal team went on
the offense did you get your crime scene
technicians that were there in order to
memorialize by cameras
that very experience that day no sir and
was that because you had only had one
case in the past dealing with
self-defense I tried my best to do the
very best job that I could if this guy
died
it's 2022 out in Pasco County Florida a
jury is listening to a mountain of
evidence in the trial of Curtis Reeves
the retired Florida police captain
charged with shooting to death Chad
Olson in a movie theater eight years
earlier while the government argued this
was murder Reeves has always maintained
he was acting in self-defense in the law
of self-defense it doesn't tell you get
smacked first
get punched first and then you can see
what you can do our goal was to place
each and every one of these jurors in
the shoes of mystery I'm 71 years old I
don't
think
that the price in my back my knees my
hands okay
I got a problem with my right eye the
guy hit me on the left side and I'm
thinking that I won't be blind you don't
have to be right in your exercise of
self-defense you just have to be
reasonable in that exercise and who
better to explain why this happened than
Curtis Reeves himself at some point do
you decide to pull your weapon
at some point I made a decision that I
had no alternative the guys in my
opinion he's completely out of control
he was so much
above me and so full of Rage I guess you
could say that he was going to strike me
with all the strength that he had or he
could put together did you shoot Mr
Olsen because
of popcorn
I shot Mr Olsen because I thought he was
gonna
seriously injure me or or
potentially kill me so sit there and
watch the lies come out of his mouth and
listen to how he was saying things and
how he showed no emotion no remorse no
sadness isn't it true that if an object
a non-deadly object
is thrown at you thrown at anybody
you can't kill that person for throwing
that object that's kind of a hard
question to answer even though he has
said to you get the F out of my face
instead of getting up and just going to
the manager you decided to lean forward
and engage him again
[Music]
they told him he left me no alternative
than to go to the management that's
right but you did not have to lean
forward and say that to him I think
Curtis did an absolute fabulous job we
work many many hours many many weeks
many many months uh with Curtis on his
cross-examination of that the
prosecution was going to have and and
certainly my direct prosecution made a
horrible mistake uh in you know
challenging you know statements that he
had made to law enforcement I think made
one of the most powerful uh answers in
this particular trial you second guessed
the very fact that you were even hit
I second guess every step of that
encounter if you are human and you have
respect for human life you would always
second-guess yourself
after all the evidence and arguments
were laid out the jury went back to
deliberate and on February 25th 2022 the
jury came back with their decision count
one murder in the second degree the
defendant is not guilty count two
aggravated battery the defendant is not
guilty both myself
and Dino Michaels always believed uh
even to the very end that we were going
to win this trial and the one thing that
I can say about Mr Reeves is that he
never gave up
on our system of justice he always
indicated to me Rick I believe in this
system uh this system is going to equip
me a
just move the camera to Nicole and it
was as if she was watching the murder
all over again the real true emotions
about this actually hit her she was an
absolute mess talking to her on the
phone I was probably doing the talking
she was just hysterical we didn't think
that the jury would allow this to happen
the impact of that verdict was felt by
many but the question of what comes next
is still being written Mr Reeves and his
wife are traveling they're trying to
catch up to the eight years uh that they
lost their been reunited with their
friends with their families they're
living life as you would want you know
two retired you know wonderful people to
uh to enjoy the remaining years of their
life well as a result of this tragic
story that Nicole and I founded the
Olsen family Foundation what we do is we
raise money for children that have
either been indirectly or directly
affected by gun violence so we're really
trying now to not focus on the negative
of Chad's murder but focus upon the
positive that can come out of it and all
the change that we hope to effectuate uh
in Florida and potentially Nationwide to
help
protect these kids that need it the Chad
Olson and Curtis Reeves story is not an
easy one to understand or really make
sense of it was a nightmare for two
families and no matter where you stand
on this case whether you agree or
disagree with the verdict I think we can
all agree this was a terrible event that
just should never have happened
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime as always thank you for joining us
and until next time
stay safe
[Music]
[Music]